Salut aujourd'hui je voulais vous parler
de trois anecdotes, trois anecdotes
historiques qui en fait sont sûrement
des légendes urbaines ces trois
anecdotes quand on me les a racontés j'ai
beaucoup aimé et quand je les racontes à
mon tour j'aime beaucoup mais j'ai fait
énormément de recherches sur le sujet
et rien ne prouve que ça s'est vraiment
passé ce qu'il n'empêche qu'elles sont
intéressantes qu'elles sont stimulantes
aussi pour la manière de penser
et c'est un petit peu comme une
friandise pour le cerveau
La première anecdote elle concerne
Picasso; Picasso quand il a eu son heure
de gloire quand il allait au restaurant
il ne payait pas son repas
et il payait en laissant un petit dessin
sur la nappe
et il y a une histoire qui raconte. On ne sait
pas si ça s'est vraiment passé ou pas
en tout cas on en a pas la preuve mais une
histoire amusante qui a raconte qu'un jour
il fait pareil son petit dessin sur la
nappe comme d'habitude le restaurateur vient
le voir
et dit : Maître c'est formidable merci
beaucoup
ça servira à payer la note il n' y a pas de problème
est-ce que vous pouvez juste me le signer avant de
partir? et Picasso aurait répondu
non je ne vais pas signer le dessin je veux juste payer ma note pas acheter le restaurant !C'est énorme!
il y en a une deuxième avec Picasso où il y a
deux versions d'ailleurs de l'histoire
je vais vous raconter celle avec un
industriel
un jour un industriel commande à
Picasso une espèce de logo une sorte de
logo
pour sa société et Picasso demande des
milliers de francs en avance et un mois
passe deux mois passent trois mois
passent et admettons cinq ou six mois
passent
et l'industriel n'a toujours pas de nouvelles de Picasso alors qu'il a versé
beaucoup d'argent
donc il va chez Picasso ! Pousser sa petite gueulante!
il arrive chez Picasso lui explique son
problème Picasso est un petit peu soulé
il prend une feuille un crayon il fait
un super logo comme ça en quelques
secondes et lui donne il fait: tenez
voici votre logo l'industriel lui dit
attendez j'ai attendu cinq mois alors
qu'il vous fallait cinq secondes pour
faire ça et Picasso aurait répondu: Non
il m'a fallu toute une vie plus de 5
secondes
pour faire ça! Ça fait partie
également de mes histoires préférées
mais dans toutes les histoires que je
connais dans ce genre
Il y en a UNE  qui est vraiment de loin
ma préférée et j'espère qu'elle
s'est passé j'espère sincèrement
qu'elle s'est passé elle concerne
Einstein quand Einstein a commencé
à être célèbre avec sa théorie sur
la relativité il a fait une tournée de
conférences aux États-Unis toutes les
universités voulaient qu'Einstein
vienne faire sa conférence avec un
petit débat après donc il a fait sa
tournée en commençant par Princeton en
finissant par Stanford il avait un
chauffeur avec lui son chauffeur
attitré
qui  a fait toute la tournée des
États-Unis  avec lui et son chauffeur assistait à
chaque conférence à chaque fois il
suivait Einstein et il écoutait tout
les questions réponses à la fin etc.. et un
jour le chauffeur a dit à Einstein
écoutez
j'ai tellement bien suivi vos conférences
je pourrais la faire à votre place sans
problème j'en suis sûr  et Einstein qui a
la réputation d'être malicieux lui
avait répondu: Ah bon?
c'est quoi la prochaine date où
est-ce qu'on va aujourd'hui? le chauffeur
dit on va à  Stanford et Einstein lui dit: ok
alors pour Stanford
vous mettez mon costume je mets le votre
et c'est vous qui faites la conférence
et c'est vraiment ce qui se passe c'est
à dire que le chauffard  d'Einstein
fait
toute la conférence devant tous
les universitaires
il gère le truc nickel à la
perfection puis à la fin de
l'exposition "on va dire" vient le temps des
questions réponses les gens posent des
questions et le maître de
conférence doit répondre sauf que là
c'est le chauffeur il s'en sort plutôt
pas mal plus que d'une université à
l'autre à peu près les mêmes questions
qui étaient posées il y a un des
universitaires pose une question très
pointu très complexe pour le chauffeur
c'est la galère et c'est là que le
chauffeur est extrêmement malin
il garde son sang froid et dit: écoutez
je suis assez étonné que vous me posiez
cette question
c'est tellement simple
que c est mon chauffeur
qui va vous répondre
et le chauffeur monte sur l'estrade
prend le micro répond à la perfection
puisque c'est Einstein! alors oui ce sont
des légendes urbaines puisqu'on ne sait
pas si ça s'est vraiment passé et si
s'est passé ce que ça s'est passé
exactement comme ça
ça n'empêche pas que ces histoires
sont intéressantes parce qu'il y a toujours une
petite leçon à en tirer
et en tout cas quand je dis que c'est un
bonbon pour le cerveau parce que à chaque
fois à chaque finalité de ces histoires on fait: Ah ouais! ok c'est cool c'est
ce qu'on appelle un "twist" j'en connais
beaucoup comme ça des légendes urbaines
sur des personnes célèbres ou sur
des faits historiques vous en connaissez
sûrement aussi c'est une de mes
passions de lire ça donc si vous en
connaissez vous les mettez dans les
commentaires et je lirais ça il y en aura
sûrement que je connais déjà mais
j'espère en apprendre des nouvelles et il
y a une nouvelle fonctionnalité
maintenant on peut épingler des
commentaires donc d'ici 24 heures
l'anecdote que je connaissais pas
j'aurais trouvé la plus amusante la
plus passionnante à lire je l'épinglerai
en Top Com'  Merci d'avoir regarder cette vidéo jusque là j'espère
que ça vous a plu d'écouter ça c'était
un truc un peu plus léger dans le
milieu de la semaine
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner si c'est
pas déjà fait et si ça vous tente et
le mental vlog c'est une vidéo par jour
pendant un an depuis le 1er janvier
jusqu'au 31 décembre qui frappe à la
porte et il arrive très très très
vite rendez-vous demain à 17 heures
tchao
ciao?